de ce chef-d'œuvre pour révéler
ce qui pouvait être dessous.
Il se trouve que celui ci est le tableau le plus important
de Léonard de Vinci que nous avons en Italie.
Regardez les images merveilleuses des visages que personne n'a vu
pendant cinq siècles. Regardez ces portraits.
Ils sont magnifiques. Nous voyons Léonard à l'œuvre.
Nous voyons la génialité de sa création exactement
sur la couche de fond du panneau. Nous voyons
cette découverte, je dirais plutôt sympa :
un éléphant. (Rires) À cause de cet éléphant
nous avons découvert 70 autres images, jamais vu pendant des siècles.
C'était une révélation. Nous sommes arrivés à comprendre
et à prouver que la couche brune que nous voyons aujourd'hui
n'a pas été faite par Léonard de Vinci, qui nous a laissé
les autres dessins que pendant cinq siècles
nous n'avons pas pus voir. Ceci grâce à la technologie.
Voyons les tablettes. Nous avons pensé que, si nous
avions tous le plaisir, le privilège de voir tout cela,
de faire toutes ces découvertes, les autres devraient pouvoir en accéder aussi.
Donc nous avons pensé à une application de réalité augmenté
pour les tablettes. Laissez-moi vous montrer une simulation
de ce que n'importe qui pourrait faire
dans un musée.
Disons que nous allons à un musée avec une tablette.
Nous orientons la caméra de la tablette
vers le tableau qui nous intéresse, comme ça.
Nous cliquons dessus, nous attendons,
et laissez-moi me tourner vers vous
pour montrer l'image que la caméra a pris.
Les images que vous avez vu du dessin
sont en train d'être chargés. Voilà.
Nous pouvons zoomer en avant et faire défiler.
D'accord ? Trouvons l'éléphant.
Tout ce qu'il faut c'est un doigt. Il suffit d'effacer
et nous voyons l'éléphant.
(Applaudissements)
D'accord ? Et puis, si nous voulons,
nous pouvons faire défiler pour retrouver, par exemple,
dans l'escalier, que toute l'iconographie changera.
Il y a un grand nombre de laïcs qui reconstruisent
un nouveau temple à partir des ruines d'un vieux temple,
et plusieurs personnages apparaissent. Vous voyez ?
Ce n'est pas uniquement une curiosité, car cela ne change pas
seulement l'iconographie comme nous la voyons, mais l'iconologie aussi,
le sens de la peinture.
Nous croyons que c'est un moyen sympa, facile,
avec lequel tout le monde peut accéder aux découvertes
et en devenir le protagoniste. Les gens ne sont plus
passifs, comme lorsque nous circulons
dans les interminables salles des musées.
(Applaudissements)
Un autre concept est le tableau clinique numérique. Il semble
très évident si nous parlons des vrais patients,
mais en ce qui concerne les œuvres d'art, malheureusement
il n'a jamais été conçu comme une idée.
Nous croyons que ça devrait être le début,
le premier pas vers la vraie préservation,
qui nous permettra de véritablement explorer et comprendre
tout ce qui concerne l'état de la préservation,
la technique, les matériels, et également si, quand et pourquoi
nous devrions restaurer, ou plutôt intervenir
dans l'environnement autour de la peinture.
Notre vision est celle de redécouvrir
l'esprit de la Renaissance et de créer une nouvelle discipline
où l'ingénierie pour le patrimoine culturel est en effet
un symbole d'union entre l'art et la science.
Nous avons absolument besoin d'un nouvel ordre d'ingénieurs
qui commenceront à faire ce genre de travail
et redécouvrir pour nous ces valeurs culturelles
dont nous avons grand besoin, surtout aujourd'hui.
Pour résumer très brièvement,
c'est ça que nous essayons de faire :
donner un avenir à notre passé,
afin de que nous puissions avoir un avenir.
Tant que nous vivons une vie de curiosité et de passion,
il y aura un peu de Léonard en chacun de nous. Merci.
(Applaudissements)